el proceso de juicio político contra el
presidente de la república ha superado
su segundo filtro luego de que la corte
constitucional admitiera el juicio
político contra el primer mandatario es
la segunda oportunidad que realiza una
votación y un debate luego que en la
primera oportunidad no alcanzará los
seis de los nuevos requeridos por parte
de los integrantes del pleno para
admitir el juicio político contra el
primer mandatario primera vez que se
realizará un juicio político contra un
presidente de la república De igual
forma primera vez que se sortean dos
jueces para tratar este tema de una
causa de interpelación contra el primer
mandatario nacional por lo tanto fueron
seis de los nueve votos pero la corte
constitucional también se pronunció en
cuanto al contenido y al proceso
presentado por parte de la asamblea
nacional hacia la corte constitucional
ha llamado la atención a la asamblea
nacional por la falta de prolijidad y
los errores que ha presentado el
parlamento ecuatoriano en la
presentación de este juicio político
bueno Gustavo que reacciones hay ante la
decisión de la corte y cuáles son las
etapas a seguir en este proceso
pero la principal reacción que se ha
producido ha sido por parte del
ejecutivo nacional la secretaría de
comunicación de la presidencia emitió
anoche un
comunicado donde rechaza la presentación
de este juicio político contra el
presidente de la república asegura que
respetará esta decisión Del máximo
órgano que interpreta la Constitución de
Ecuador pero no acepta también los
postulados presentados por parte de los
interpelantes asegura que si bien se
acepta este proceso de juicio político
asegura que este interpelación no tiene
sustento jurídico en contra el primer
mandatario nacional qué va a pasar ahora
bueno continúa el proceso luego se
remite este informe de admisibilidad al
órgano calificador el consejo
administrativo de la legislatura
Posteriormente
prosigue la defensa del primer
mandatario nacional y deberá presentarse
ante el pleno del parlamento para
defenderse posible escenario la
resolución de la asamblea nacional pero
El Ejecutivo ha dicho que no la
presentará que el presidente se
defenderá ante el parlamento ecua
toriano